monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur mr et culture et d'alimentation
mais je crois que c'est madame le
ministre de la transition écologique qui
va me répondre
il s'agit d'un sujet qui touche un pan
entier de l'économie agricole
cela fait déjà deux mois que les
conchyliculteurs et les ostréiculteurs
bien évidemment font face à une
contamination de leur production par un
virus c'est un phénomène qui est
récurrent mais qui n'avait jamais pris
une telle ampleur
il y à de nombreuses productions
conchylicole qui sont touchés en
méditerranée dans la manche sur la côte
atlantique dans le morbihan ce sont deux
entreprises sur trois qui ont été
fermées à un moment de temps dû à ce
virus c'est une catastrophe économique
et sociale
ces entreprises sont souvent petites
halles sont souvent familiales et pour
certaines d'entre elles
eh bien elles font 60 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires sur cette période donc il ne
vous a pas échappé qu'elle correspondait
à la période des fêtes de fin d'année
alors c'est une situation qui appelle
deux types de réponses la première a
très vraisemblablement au traitement des
eaux usées et cette réponse est en cours
la deuxième est bien nécessite de faire
face à l'urgence il y a effectivement
une urgence on pourrait admettre que les
conchyliculteurs font face à une
situation dont ils ne sont pas
responsables dont ils ne sont pas la
cause et ils en appellent à la
solidarité nationale bien évidemment
lors des réunions se sont tenues au
ministère de l'agriculture
j'ai cru comprendre que leur teneur
était que et bien les préfets devront
recenser
quels étaient les préjudices et que les
aides existantes seraient mises en
oeuvre au profit des conchyliculteurs
mais en réalité sur le terrain il ne se
passe rien les professionnels ne voit
évidemment dans l'immédiatement dans
l'immédiat rien venir et il faudrait et
je vous demande madame le ministre de
m'indiquer comment vous comptez venir en
aides aux conchyliculteurs durablement
est durement touchée la question est
assez simple les conchyliculteurs
vont-ils être aidées par l'état de
quelle façon
à quelle hauteur selon quel calendrier
et je voudrais même le ministre que vous
puissiez être la plus précise et
concrète possible
c'est ce qu'attendent les entreprises et
les salariés qui sont en difficulté je
vous remercie